النار بالنار من المسلسلات اللي كانت
مشاركه في الموسم الرمضاني الاخير وحقيقه
حقق نجاح كبير ونسبه مشاهده واسعه وهو من
بطوله كاريس بشار وعابد فهد وجورج خباز
وغيرهم ومن تاليف رامي كوسا واخراج محمد
عبد العزيز لكن من وقت عرضه في حوله
الكثير من الجدل مو بس بسبب مناقشته
لمواضيع حساسه او جدليه لكن كمان بسبب اخذ
ارض صار بين كاتب العمل ومخرجوا واتهامات
متبادله والكلام عن هذا الجدل اتجدد امس
مع ظهور بطله العمل النجمه السوريه كاريس
بشار في برنامج كلام نواعم وكلامها عن قله
امانه صارت في العمل وقصقصه وحذف واضافه
[ضحك]
24 حلقه
كلام كاريس بشار جاء متفق مع كلام بيقولوا
المؤلف رامي كوسا من اول ايام رمضان وطلع
رامي كوسا في بوس مطول على فيسبوك وقال
انه كريس انصفتو وقال ها هي نجمه العمل
تؤكد روايتي وتتحدث عن قله الامانه وعن
السرقه وعن تفسيخ المقوله وعن استغياب
الاخرين وقال انه اللي قالته كريس غيض من
فيض وان هو نفسه لم يبح بعد بكل ما لديه
ويرجو ان لا يضطروا احمد احمق مخادع ما
لقول ما يزيد الطين بلم طيب المؤلف رامي
كوسا على فكره من اول رمضان وهو بيقول هذا
الكلام وكان له كل يوم تقريبا سلسله
بوستات بيتكلم فيها عن تحويل جالس بيصير
في العمل ووجه اتهامات للمخرج والمخرج طلع
مره في تصريحات واكد انه اللي صار في
المسلسل النصف غير جائر لكن قال كمان انه
كان متفق عليه وانه النص اصلا كان في
مشاكل خلينا نقول او كيف مواصفها هو
بنيويه
وانه رامي كان على اطلاع بكل التعديلات
وصار في اخذ ورد كثير اليوم كريس وقفت في
صف رامي كوسا اما المخرج فلان مصدر عنه او
عن شركه الانتاج اي تعليق على تصريحات
النجمه